Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 219 to David P on the bonus show yesterday,
I told stories about my flights out and
back from California. I also talked about
the homeless problem in San Francisco.
In fact, I didn't criticize the homeless
people. I said San Francisco didn't cause
homelessness. The eggman apparently didn't
like what I had to say. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave. I'm just a little
bit disappointed in how you described the homeless
people. Sorry. These and the camps and stuff that
you saw while visiting San Francisco. Personally,
when I see stuff like that, I go over and interact
with people. I meet them, I talk to them. Okay.
Speaker 1: I drove by the encampments
on the way to an event. I'm sorry, Eggman. I
didn't stop to talk to people at the encampment.
I'm sorry I didn't do it. You're right.
Speaker 2: Hi. With them, I buy them some food, I
hang out. Maybe they buy me some food, maybe they
get me high. So those are just people that I want
to meet and talk to a lot more than people on an
airplane stuffing purses and bags in an overhead.
Speaker 1: I was not stuffing 50 bags in overhead.
I brought on a roller board and a and a personal
item. My girlfriend brought on a roller
board and a personal item. And then we had
the foldable baby stroller, which folds right
into the overhead. And then we had a diaper
bag. Okay. There was nothing crazy going on.
Speaker 2: Dragging a kid around. I mean, look,
I would love to hang out with you,
but I would much more like to hang
out with somebody living in RV in San Francisco.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, I'm sorry, Egg man. Go
and drive to San Francisco and hang out at the RV.
I'm sorry I failed the egg man when it came to the
encampments. All right. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. I won't even tell you what's
on it because I'm running so behind. But it's a
great bonus show. I encourage you to check it out.